[Music]
to many of us einstein was a genius
because he worked in advanced quantum
physics which can often seem like an
abstract science with very little
relevance to our daily lives
but in fact the world of quantum physics
is the same world we inhabit every day
from the relativity that makes gps
possible to the quantum mechanics
insider smoke alarms we are surrounded
by evidence of how our everyday world
connects to the exotic world pioneered
by einstein and others in the 20th
century
my name is chad orzelle i'm a professor
of physics and author of how to teach
quantum physics to your dog
in this course i'll show you how quantum
physics underlies many of the mundane
phenomena and technologies that we
experience every day
this is not a course you need a phd to
understand all you'll need is to have
experienced the glow of a toaster or the
tick of a clock you'll learn how
discoveries theories and even mistakes
gave us technology and inventions that
we take for granted join me on a journey
that will inspire you to look at the
world around you with new eyes and find
wonder in even the most mundane aspects
of daily life